welcome to this video playing GM Jack
Daniels that's fine probable my letting
melittin okay I think this guy is pretty
high rated not sure though I mean it's I
rated T in the Blitz but I mean over the
board ok we get the scotch scotch four
nights ok yeah this is the latest
fashion this is a ch3 business giving
wide them maybe a little-little more to
play for it sets but Sir it's am an idea
I'm played by Crom naked number of times
and I'm trying to react quickly here
it's not not kill IAM if what I'm
playing is the most precise but it
should be okay in a way maybe age six or
something okay I may be healthy form
and I just take and Bishop be six maybe
90 force coming yeah maybe here to sort
of get this straight going maybe you can
place he fall yeah I think I probably
played it a player yeah I played not
very precisely yep if I blunder this
point I definitely didn't how stupid is
that I was only thinking about those end
games okay Jim
now I know it's really just a poor now
for a zip and pip may be here I can can
go to see 3m fear Bishop age seven
that's not working
yes Queen age five sometime yeah I don't
know I don't know let's do that
now is Queen age five still I can cannot
take on f4 I just blunder this blood eh
porn after that you're really end in
terrible shape I always hated if I make
life very easy for my for my opponents
it's really just plundering upon this is
just bad okay um I have to take one if I
will take with this pawn yeah I mean
maybe I have some some ideas this is
support this Bishop is really really bad
and they will always have C form
maybe you look b5 if you are intending
g5 and and some stuff
LG 50 yeah g5 is a threat time I thought
gee 523 but it's also Queen f4 so g5
really is a threat um yeah can I somehow
work with rook to g5 like this one
look f5 some stuff he's got 93 m maybe I
can provoke some weaknesses here at
least
queen bee six then maybe a five or
something
I mean I have a key plundering stuff
yeah oh just just a bloody porn I really
feel without blundering of those bonds
it would have been more interesting you
know don't blunder blunder the the pawn
I'm not sure that it is that easy for
him to win of course he's better and
everything and so on but there are some
structural issues with this position and
I voice good now probably I a carefully
form
I want to go King g65 impossible just in
time
Chet hi morning yeah well that was a
really real reason I crappy game yeah
what did i do there that was
embarrassing really blundering to plot
points with one movers yeah well this is
just fairly normal position where not
much is going on yeah I don't know any
move but Queen c7 basically which is
just ridiculous yeah just whatever yeah
I mean this is just a normal normal
normal position maybe I can go here or
play this and this I mean why does why
did white can try to claim a small edge
with moose like see form but it's a it's
very very little and yeah we're just not
blundering upon after that it was a and
it was just worse and I mean I kept I
kept fighting but why was blundering yet
another pawn it could have taken here
where he could have taken here already
and here Bishop f5 but ok it's just a an
uphill struggle after this h6 blunder
yeah lesson learned from this game don't
blunder pawns very surprising ok thanks
for watching